the one meal i wish i could have
delivered to the bubble
multiple dishes it can't just be like
chicken what's up bleacher report
it's cj mccollum here live from the
bubble it's been an adjustment
being in a hotel room i think the
highlight so far has been being able to
watch a lot of games being able to play
cards
one thing i do miss when traveling day
to day is the food
the food other types of food when we're
on the road
i typically choose the restaurants
depending on what city we're in
in cities like houston we always try to
go to the breakfast club
because it's really good it's black
owned and you got a lot of soul food
options
you got the shrimp and grits chicken and
waffles the fried chicken is crispy
a little bit of hot sauce got the
waffles you get the savory taste
syrup they also have this like orange
drink just how uh
grandma used to make it and then going
to other cities
like memphis you got blue city cafe
catfish i can go with ribs
pulled get that soul food in and the key
is to make sure you get a workout in the
morning because you're going to overload
for us whenever we have a chance to go
to a small business
we take advantage of it we understand
the importance especially in times like
this
when kovid first hit and they start the
season down we did a lot of cooking at
home
and then we basically gathered a list of
small businesses that we could support
and begin going and that's just one of
the ways in which we try to
to help give back i want to thank
bleacher report and google for
having me on i want to remind everyone
out there to keep supporting businesses
near you
keep supporting black businesses keep
supporting minority businesses
and keep showing love peace
you